has your porn and sex addiction affected
your studies work marriage and family
relationship are you stuck with feelings
of guilt shame remorse and despair or
has your addiction progressed from
pornography to zinna well we're here to
tell you you're not alone itasca is the
place where muslim males and females
struggling with pornography addictions
can find recovery and freedom
you see guys sometimes in life
allah tells us not to do certain things
but we don't listen we don't listen we
do them we suffer we get hurt
and
well that might be it some people go
down the route of repenting and changing
their ways like adam ali salaam he made
a mistake and he said well that was my
fault but something sometimes some
certain people and i'm not saying this
brother but sadly certain people move in
a way they act like iblis they start
blaming allah i'm not that's why he said
because you misguided me now in this
video this brother is talking about
something that he may have gone through
and he's saying that he lost his trust
in allah so let's watch it and we're
going to take some advice from that
the thing that i want to mention is the
following so he says something along the
lines of i've got my belief something
something
23 i lost a lot of
mandam on the street i lost my trust in
allah so i don't pray to the east
something along those lines okay yeah um
and the question that i need to ask is
very simple yeah
you lost a lot of friends to the streets
now in what way
i'm trying to say now if they are on in
the road life sending drugs i'm not
saying they did or they didn't my point
is this if they are involved in gang
life what do you expect would you expect
for them to happen is this it's like me
jumping in water and getting upset
because i'm wet now i'm sorry that you
lost friends i'm not here to have a go
at you or them but the point is the
following
how will you lose and trust allah and
not praying to the east yeah and by the
way allah says taqwa is not praying to
the east or the west it doesn't matter
it's internal it's not about where you
dress up or which way you shape and
you're taking that out on allah by
distancing yourself from him when who is
at fault here we are at fault if i'm in
a gang when back in the days i was
involved in gang and stuff like that
when people that i knew died or people i
knew got into an injury or whatever it
may be how can i blame allah when i'm in
that field of destruction
so the point i wanted to make in this
video in a nation i don't want to
longing out too much is you've got two
choices you either act like adam alaiham
or iblees adam made a mistake he
repented he didn't blame allah he blamed
himself or you move like iblis and say
no it's your fault so the fact that you
trusted losing trust in allah is a
statement of quran yeah because we
should always have tawan allah so my
advice to you brother and anyone out
there is that if there's certain things
that you have done in your life blame
yourself allah will never send you
something to cause you calamity and some
things that may be a calamity it is
better for you so learn a mistake from
your friends dying avoid the street life
i'm not saying you're in it or not but
in general those who are watching or
whatever you're doing take a lesson from
this and change your ways and you should
have more trust in allah because allah
told you from the get-go to not do these
thirds and things that may be haram
that's my advice and i hope you guys
benefit inshaallah for i'll do that and
send this video to him i've got no hard
feelings to brothers watching i'm not
going to go at you genuinely i'm just
trying to give you sincereness here
because allah says indeed and this here
benefits a believer till next time guys
salaam alaikum welcome to life